les dernières sanctions contre la russie
viennent de deux géants mondiaux visa et
mastercard ont annoncé samedi suspendre
leurs opérations sur les territoires
russe en raison du caractère sans
précédent du conflit actuel et de
l'environnement économique incertain
nous avons décidé de suspendre notre
réseau de service en russie suivie
immédiatement par le concurrent visa
l'annoncent est lourde de conséquences
sur la population
très concrètement en termes de
conséquences pour pour les russes et
pour la population russe c'est une
incapacité par exemple d'honorer chat
qui pourrait faire à l'étranger les
cartes mastercard et visa pourront
continuer à être utilisés sur le
territoire russe par des russes est
exclusivement russie ce qui compte ce
qui me vient parachever cet isolement et
cette autarcie du système bancaire russe
depuis le début de la guerre en ukraine
de nombreuses entreprises se retire de
russie vendredi dernier les géants du
luxe lvmh hermès et chanel ont annoncé
la fermeture temporaire de leurs
magasins sur le territoire
ces sanctions du secteur privé s'ajoute
à la pression exercée par les puissances
occidentales
exclusion partielle du système swift gel
des avoirs et boycott commercial des
mesures inédites sur lesquels mise
l'occident pour obtenir le retrait des
forces russes sans avoir à intervenir
militairement